to refocus our attention.
We actually cycle through two different projects
before we come back to the original thing we were doing.
This is Gloria Mark's research combined with Microsoft research,
that showed this.
And her research also shows that it actually trains bad habits.
The more interruptions we get externally,
it's conditioning and training us to interrupt ourselves.
We actually self-interrupt every three-and-a-half minutes.
This is crazy.
So how do we fix this?
Because Nancy and John are in this all-or-nothing relationship.
Nancy might want to disconnect,
but then she'd be worried:
What if I'm missing something important?
Design can fix this problem.
Let's say you have Nancy again on the left,
John on the right.
And John remembers, "I need to send Nancy that document."
Except this time,
Nancy can mark that she's focused.
Let's say she drags a slider and says,
"I want to be focused for 30 minutes,"
so -- bam -- she's focused.
Now when John wants to message her,
he can get the thought off of his mind --
because he has a need, he has this thought,
and he needs to dump it out before he forgets.
Except this time,
it holds the messages so that Nancy can still focus,
but John can get the thought off of his mind.
But this only works if one last thing is true,
which is that Nancy needs to know that if something is truly important,
John can still interrupt.
But instead of having constant accidental or mindless interruptions,
we're now only creating conscious interruptions,
So we're doing two things here.
We're creating a new choice for both Nancy and John,
But there's a second, subtle thing we're doing here, too.
And it's that we're changing the question we're answering.
Instead of the goal of chat being:
"Let's design it so it's easy to send a message" --
that's the goal of chat,
it should be really easy to send a message to someone --
we change the goal to something deeper and a human value,
which is: "Let's create the highest possible quality communication
in a relationship between two people.
So we upgraded the goal.
Now, do designers actually care about this?
Do we want to have conversations about what these deeper human goals are?
Well, I'll tell you one story.
A little over a year ago,
I got to help organize a meeting
between some of technology's leading designers and Thich Nhat Hanh.
Thich Nhat Hanh is an international spokesperson for mindfulness meditation.
And it was the most amazing meeting.
You have to imagine -- picture a room --
on one side of the room, you have a bunch of tech geeks;
on the other side of the room,
you have a bunch of long brown robes, shaved heads, Buddhist monks.
And the questions were about the deepest human values,
like what does the future of technology look like
when you're designing for the deepest questions
and the deepest human values?
And our conversation centered on listening more deeply
to what those values might be.
He joked in our conversation
that what if, instead of a spell check,
you had a compassion check,
meaning, you might highlight a word that might be accidentally abrasive --
perceived as abrasive by someone else.
So does this kind of conversation happen in the real world,
not just in these design meetings?
Well, the answer is yes,
and one of my favorites is Couchsurfing.
If you didn't know, Couchsurfing is a website
that matches people who are looking for a place to stay
with a free couch, from someone who's trying to offer it.
So, great service --
what would their design goal be?
What are you designing for if you work at Couchsurfing?
Well, you would think it's to match guests with hosts.
Right?
That's a pretty good goal.
But that would kind of be like our goal with messaging before,
where we're just trying to deliver a message.
So what's the deeper, human goal?
Well, they set their goal
as the need to create lasting, positive experiences and relationships
between people who've never met before.
And the most amazing thing about this was in 2007,
they introduced a way to measure this,
which is incredible.
I'll tell you how it works.
For every design goal you have,
you have to have a corresponding measurement
to know how you're doing --
a way of measuring success.
So what they do is,
let's say you take two people who meet up,
and they take the number of days those two people spent together,
and then they estimate how many hours were in those days --
how many hours did those two people spend together?
And then after they spend that time together,
they ask both of them:
How positive was your experience?
Did you have a good experience with this person that you met?
And they subtract from those positive hours
the amount of time people spent on the website,
because that's a cost to people's lives.
Why should we value that as success?
And what you were left with
is something they refer to as "net orchestrated conviviality,"
or, really, just a net "Good Times" created.
The net hours that would have never existed, had Couchsurfing not existed.
Can you imagine how inspiring it would be to come to work every day
and measure your success
in the actual net new contribution of hours in people's lives
that are positive, that would have never existed
if you didn't do what you were about to do at work today?
Can you imagine a whole world that worked this way?
Can you imagine a social network that --
let's say you care about cooking,
and it measured its success in terms of cooking nights organized
and the cooking articles that you were glad you read,
and subtracted from that the articles you weren't glad you read
or the time you spent scrolling that you didn't like?
Imagine a professional social network
that, instead of measuring its success in terms of connections created
or messages sent,
instead measured its success in terms of the job offers that people got
that they were excited to get.
And subtracted the amount of time people spent on the website.
Or imagine dating services,
like maybe Tinder or something,
where instead of measuring the number of swipes left and right people did,
which is how they measure success today,
instead measured the deep, romantic, fulfilling connections people created.
Whatever that was for them, by the way.
But can you imagine a whole world that worked this way,
that was helping you spend your time well?
Now to do this you also need a new system,
because you're probably thinking,
today's Internet economy --
today's economy in general --
is measured in time spent.
The more users you have,
the more usage you have,
the more time people spend,
that's how we measure success.
But we've solved this problem before.
We solved it with organic,
when we said we need to value things a different way.
We said this is a different kind of food.
So we can't compare it just based on price;
this is a different category of food.
We solved it with Leed Certification,
where we said this is a different kind of building
that stood for different values of environmental sustainability.
What if we had something like that for technology?
What if we had something whose entire purpose and goal
was to help create net new positive contributions to human life?
And what if we could value it a different way,
so it would actually work?
Imagine you gave this different premium shelf space on app stores.
Imagine you had web browsers that helped route you
to these kinds of design products.
Can you imagine how exciting it would be to live and create that world?
We can create this world today.
Company leaders, all you have to do --
only you can prioritize a new metric,
which is your metric for net positive contribution to human life.
And have an honest conversation about that.
Maybe you're not doing so well to start with,
but let's start that conversation.
Designers, you can redefine success; you can redefine design.
Arguably, you have more power than many people in your organization
to create the choices that all of us live by.
Maybe like in medicine,
where we have a Hippocratic oath
to recognize the responsibility and this higher value
that we have to treat patients.
What if designers had something like that,
in terms of this new kind of design?
And users, for all of us --
we can demand technology that works this way.
Now it may seem hard,
but McDonald's didn't have salads until the consumer demand was there.
Walmart didn't have organic food until the consumer demand was there.
We have to demand this new kind of technology.
And we can do that.
And doing that
would amount to shifting from a world that's driven and run
entirely on time spent,
to world that's driven by time well spent.
I want to live in this world,
and I want this conversation to happen.
Let's start that conversation now.
Thank you.
(Applause)